what's up folks raj here back with
another kubernetes interview question
and answer video lot of you said my
previous videos the questions were a
little bit moderate too advanced and you
wanted me to cover some must know
questions more on the basic level so in
this video we are going to do that
so these questions are must know like i
said
so make sure you study this either from
this video or externally so questions we
are going to cover today are
is kubernetes the only container
orchestrator name another container
orchestrator from aws
why should you choose eks or elastic
kubernetes service
tell me the high level workflow of micro
service in kubernetes what is the
difference between horizontal part
autoscaler and cluster autoscaler
what is the difference between cluster
autoscaler and carpenter
what is the difference between demon set
and side car
what are kubernetes control plan
components
name some tools which can monitor
kubernetes
how would you do kubernetes logging
what is eks add-on name some eks add-ons
what is the difference between ingress
and service
name a couple things you do and do not
like about kubernetes
what is a multi-stage build and finally
now the docker desktop charges money or
it has a license paid license
will that impact your kubernetes
workload so so the last one is a trick
question but make sure you know the
answer
just a quick announcement all my cloud
devops courses on udemy are on sale so
you can get the maximum discount
possible but this is only for next four
days
the best way to get the discount is go
to my website cloudwithraj.com
and once you are there you can click
this banner spring cell on all cloud
devops courses or you can simply scroll
down and under my top courses you will
see all my
courses listed so if you are interested
learning about git and github system
design kubernetes serverless
cloudformation
you can simply click this discounted
udemy link and it will open up the udemy
page along with the discount coupon
already applied
i'll give the link in the description
all right let's get back to the video so
question number one is kubernetes the
only container orchestrator
the answer is no there are many other
orchestrators such as aperture messes
docker swarm etc
what is another content orchestrator
from aws
amazon ecs or elastic container service
next question why should you choose eks
or elastic kubernetes service so
basically interviewer wants to see if
you know the advantages of eks the first
one is eks is upstream and certified
confirmed version of kubernetes so this
is like a fancy line what it means is if
you are running kubernetes today with
some open source kubernetes tools uh
maybe you are running this kubernetes
workload in on-prem or another cloud the
eks is a certified confirmation version
that means you can bring your existing
workload as well as the tools you are
running today on kubernetes elsewhere to
eks without any problem eks also
supports four versions of kubernetes at
one time
so currently it supports version one
point two two two one two zero and one
nine so this gives you sufficient time
to upgrade to the next version the
biggest advantage of eks is amazon
manages the control plane for you so
currently if you are managing the
kubernetes yourself you know the biggest
pinpoint is to manage your control plane
to make it highly available and scalable
some of the component of control plane
is very critical such as hcd so if you
lose hcd you will lose the whole cluster
with eks aws runs the control plane in
three different availability zone
including hcd
also as the cluster grows in size amazon
eks will automatically scale the control
plane so that you don't experience
slowness another thing to keep in mind
is each eks cluster has its separate and
dedicated control plane even if you are
running multiple cluster the control
planes are not shared
next big advantage with eks customers
have less management overhead so when
you say this expect the interviewer
asking you why or how so you have to
name couple of these big features such
as managed node group with manage node
group you can upgrade your kubernetes
version for the worker node with one
click of a button or one api call
and while it's upgrading the worker
nodes it will keep your application up
and running so it will do a rolling
deployment and it will respect the pod
disruption budget
what that means is if you specify a
certain percentage of pods to be up and
running this managed node group will do
that for you
second advantage is managed add-ons so
when you run a kubernetes cluster you
have to install some additional software
for your production workload
with eks some of the add-ons are managed
by aws so aws gives you the software to
install if something get needs to be
upgraded aws gives you the upgraded copy
and also if something goes wrong you can
open aws support ticket and ws will help
you fix it
some of the examples of managed add-ons
for eks are bpc cni a dot etc and the
other big advantage is for your worker
nodes eks provides the amis creating and
maintaining an ami is a painful task
especially if there is a security
vulnerability you have to fix it
yourself with aws provided a case
optimized mi aws gives you the amis it
fixes security vulnerabilities and you
can just grab the ami and use it
directly amazonic s is cost effective it
costs 10 cents per hour for the control
plan and the data plan cost is based on
what kind of ec2 you are using and
whether you are using forget
this is also eligible for savings plan
so if you have a contract with aws the
cost will come down even further
and the last but not the least mention
this point because not many interviewees
are going to mention this say that other
large-scale enterprises running eks so
eks can be trusted to run secure and
large workload some of the publicly
referenceable examples are hsbc bank
amazon and snapchat i like to give these
three examples because hsbc bank
exemplifies that it can run secure
workload and amazon and snapchat the
volume is crazy so it demonstrates that
eks can handle very high traffic the
next question is tell me the high level
flow of micro services so i'm going to
give you the high level flow of how
things get deployed into kubernetes and
then the micro services
so your developer checks in the code and
the docker file in a repository and then
you create the container image using
this docker file and then this container
image is saved in a container repository
one example would be docker hub or
amazon ecr
and then from this amazon ecr this
container
will get deployed into a kubernetes
cluster
so let's say for example we are using
amazon ec2 for worker node and then you
will use a kubernetes deploy to deploy
the container into the running ec2 the
container image don't just run by itself
it is encapsulated by pod so the pod is
the smallest deployable unit in
kubernetes
so when it needs to scale the container
image just doesn't scale by itself the
pods needs to scale first
but then how will this pod get exposed
to outside world so you will use
kubernetes service and with a specific
kind of service such as load balancer
anyone from outside the kubernetes
cluster can call this so this is
essentially a microservice
next question what is the difference
between horizontal part auto scaler and
cluster auto scaler this question can be
alternatively asked can you tell me how
will you scale your workloads in
kubernetes so the way it works is as
traffic increases the cpu and memory
utilization of pod goes up and then you
use hpa or horizontal part auto scaler
and for horizontal power rescaler will
dictate at what percentage of cpu or
memory usage you will create another pod
so i'm just saying cpu and memory
because those are the most commonly used
parameter
but using other tools such as scada you
can also use other metrics other than
cpu and memory
but anyway coming back so using
horizontal parameter scalar
you create another pod in the same
amazon ec2
but remember amazon ec2 also have a cpu
and memory so a certain point after
certain number of pods uh spin up in
this amazon ec2 instance the cpu of this
amazon c2 reaches a critical threshold
and using cluster auto scaler you spin
up additional amazon ec2 and then more
pods could be scheduled in those amazon
situ's horizontal power scaler and
cluster auto scaler
is a big topic and you should know this
in detail so i have separate videos
going over hpa and cluster autoscaler
i'll give the link up top so please make
sure you study those either from my
videos or you can study yourself
externally but make sure you study those
before going to interviews next question
is what is the difference between
cluster autoscaler and carpenter so
regular cluster autoscaler without
carpenter just pins up a similar ec2
node so basically ec2 m5 large it keeps
spinning up whenever there is a part
that needs to be scheduled it spins up
but let's say a new type of workload
comes into the cluster and this requires
some gpu ec2
so regular auto scaler will not be able
to schedule that part and the way around
is you have to create a different
compute node group
so basically you will have a node group
for m5 large another node group for gpu
and once you do that
then another gpu ec2 can come up and gpu
workload will get scheduled
with carpenter you don't need to create
this separate kind of node groups not
only it can spin up any kind of ec2
without the need of you defining
different load node groups but also it
can resize the instances it's not stuck
to just ec2 m5 large like previous
example if it makes sense to spin up a
let's say c5 2x large and fit all the
pods in there it can do that as well
next question this one is very important
as well
what is the demand set and what is the
side curve or you could be asked what is
the difference between demand set and
side car
so demand set ensures that all the nodes
of your kubernetes worker plane run a
copy of a pod whenever you get this kind
of question always give an example
so one example of demonstrate could be
fluent d or fluent bit for logging so
every worker node of your kubernetes
cluster will run a pod for fluent d or
flint bit and then for fluent fluent bit
is used for a logging and then it will
gather the logs and then send it out to
your logging system whereas site car is
another container will run inside a pod
alongside your application container so
one example of site car is istio because
istio controls traffic it needs to sit
right by your application container to
work as a proxy
so the next question is what are the
kubernetes control plane components so
the control plane has the following
components the api server
so api server is the component of the
kubernetes control plane that exposes
the kubernetes api
so think of it as whenever you are
running a cube cubectl command
it is actually going to the api server
so that is the part of the kubernetes
cluster that's exposed to you so next
part is lcd so hcd is like the hard disk
of your kubernetes cluster it's a
consistent and highly available key
value store used as kubernetes backing
store
so basically this hcd saves your
kubernetes secrets also it stores how
many nodes are running what workload
running in what nodes etc
so if you lose that cd you're gonna lose
the cluster so that's why amazon eks
runs three copies of lcd in three
different availabilities on in its
control plane hcd is not kubernetes
specific it is also an open source uh
consistent and highly available key
value store kubernetes just adopted it
to be used with kubernetes
next one is a scheduler or cube
scheduler so this is the control plane
component uh whenever you need to create
a new part so let's say you do a cube
ctl apply and then a deployment
and then the scheduler schedules the
pods
so it goes and checks which
worker node has a capacity and then it
schedules that part if there are no more
capacity in the worker node for that pod
it interacts with auto scaling groups or
carpenter and then spins up new node so
that's what scheduler do it also
understands things like affinity
anti-affinity data locality etc
so the next component is cube controller
manager or controller manager or
controller
so this is the component that ensures
that the desired state of the cluster
is matching with the current state so my
favorite example that i use is a
replication controller so let's say you
deploy a deployment and the pod should
have 10 replicas and for some reason two
replicas go down so the replication
controller keeps on checking what's the
desired state and the desired state is
listed in hcd and the current state now
deviated from the desired state so the
current state is eight part desired is
ten so the replication controller will
kick in and then work with the scheduler
to schedule two more pods
so similarly there are different
controller node controller job
controller endpoint controller etc each
of these controls the desired state
matches with the current state so the
last one it is additional if you are
running kubernetes cluster in the cloud
so let's say for aws because with the
cloud there are some cloud specific
concepts such as the nodes or amazon
ec2's uh so for the node controller for
eks checks with aws to determine if a
ec2 instance has been deleted in the
cloud after it stops responding what
should the behavior be be etc
similarly for service controller let's
say you are using a load balancer
service
so basically it has to interact with aws
elastic load balancer uh you got the
idea even though this question was about
control plane components but also study
the node components as well especially
cubelet and q proxy i'll give the link
in the description or you can just
google kubernetes components and this
official kubernetes page should come up
next question name some tools which can
monitor kubernetes
so whenever someone talks about
monitoring always think of metrics and
alarms so metrics could be the metrics
for cpu memory or some application
specific such as how many connections or
traffic and then based on that alarm so
the most popular monitoring tool is a
prometheus and so prometheus collects
all the data in a time series format and
then using graphana
you can create metrics on top of it
prometheus also has a component called
alert manager and using alert manager
you can send alerts
such as if the cpu utilization of a
particular node goes to 95 percent
etc i have a separate video on
prometheus and grafana so please check
them out this is also a very important
topic now if you want to impress the
interviewer you can mention aws a dot or
aws distributed open telemetry so
whenever you use prometheus the open
source prometheus you have to grab the
package install it yourself
with a dot it's a managed add-on so aws
gives you the total software and the
biggest advantage of a dot is a dot not
only does monitoring
but it can do that tracing as well
a dot integrates directly with container
insights so instead of using prometheus
you can use container insights and
container insights already have the
metrics built in so you don't have to go
define metrics like you have to do in
grafana
and also container inside server is
managed by aws so even if your cluster
scales like crazy aws will scale the
container inside's infrastructure to
keep up with it
which goes in nicely with the next
question how do you do kubernetes
logging you could have a fluent d fluent
beat those are the very popular demon
sets and fluently fluent bit can collect
the logs and send it to your preferred
choice of logging solution
you can send the logs to cloudwatch logs
or you can send it to third-party
logging system such as splunk
elasticsearch etc
next question what are eks add-ons name
some examples
so when you provision a kubernetes
cluster since it's open source you also
have to install some additional software
for different functionality
uh i just mentioned fluentd fluent bit
for logging prometheus for monitoring
so you have to install all that stuff
those are what we call as add-ons now
some of the add-ons aws manages it and
in this diagram you could see such as
ppc cni core dns ebs csi q proxy
as well as recently released a dot
but some of the add-ons you need to
install yourself
such as if you are using traffic as
ingress or engine x helm argo cd etc
so i wanted to mention here in case
interviewer asks so this is a lot of
overhead i'm installing all these
add-ons what is the best way to handle
this so you could say that the newly
released open source project from aws
called aws eks blueprints
gives you
complete examples and terraform uh
modules to provision cluster with all
the add-ons along with the security best
practices built in
so for example this complete kubernetes
add-ons gives you the terraform to spin
up kubernetes cluster along with
installed add-ons right so which is
pretty amazing if let's say you want to
use cross-plane
so it gives an example it brings up a
case cluster and it installs cross-plane
aws keeps this repository up to date as
eks gets upgraded or new tools and
feature come in aws will keep this
repository up to date i'll do a separate
video on this going over with a demo so
keep an eye out for that
next question what is the difference
between ingress and service
so i went over how does a micro service
architecture looks like in answer to a
previous question
so check it out if you haven't now
extending that concept so the way
service is implemented for external
facing microservice is using a load
balancer
so each service will have its separate
load balancer
so if you have three different micro
service
let's say slash browse slash buy slash
refund you'll have three different load
balancer and each load balancer will
have a separate url so the disadvantages
of services it's expensive to maintain
one load balancer per service because
now you have three load balancers
no url based routing because each load
balancer will have its own separate url
if you want to use a common url and then
slash browse slash buy slash refund you
have to have a global load balancer on
top of this three load bouncer which
adds even more cost and maintenance
so there is a maintenance overhead of
managing separate services
so aws ingress solves that challenge
so aws ingress is an object where it can
do
path-based routing
and it can route traffic to different
pods for different url and it uses one
load balancer in this case the traffic
for three different microservices coming
to the same aws ingress which means one
elastic load balancer one url it can use
the url-based routing and they're
routing to different pods for these
three different microservices so i have
a separate video on ingress so please
check it out i'll give the link up top
so next question is name couple things
you like and do not like about
kubernetes i like this question because
it kind of shows
that you have actually tried kubernetes
hands-on and not just read theories
as i'll name two uh advantages and
disadvantages
so the biggest advantage of kubernetes
is portability
if you are running a kubernetes workload
today in on-prem and you want to move to
cloud a tomorrow or maybe aws the next
day
you could do that all the workload and
the container image and the tools you
are using you can just carry them over
next biggest advantage is the open
source and vibrant community
so whenever you need an example of
something for a specific micro service
or maybe how to use a specific cncf
approved add-on there are so many
examples so it's very easy to find
a proof of concept and then try it out
another advantage even though i said i
will give you two
is uh
you can choose the underlying
infrastructure let's say you are running
kubernetes in virtual machine
and your workload is a gpu intensive
workload or maybe memory intensive you
can choose the infrastructure based on
that
in some of the services let's say ws
lambda
you can run your micro service but you
cannot choose anything other than the
memory you don't have any way to choose
whether you can run the lambda in a gpu
infrastructure or not kubernetes you can
change the infrastructure based on your
workload
now couple of disadvantages of
kubernetes is a steep learning curve
because if you are running kubernetes on
cloud
you have to learn the cloud components
that's there
but that's not enough you also have to
learn kubernetes concepts so for example
if you want to scale kubernetes pods
you need to learn kubernetes concepts
like horizontal part of scalar metric
server cluster auto scaler and you also
have to learn aws components so it kind
of
the knowledge curve is little bit steep
second disadvantage is
because it's so flexible
the day to operation could be a
challenge kubernetes has a lot of moving
components and for each functional area
you will install some sort of open
source tool
like fluency fluent bit prometheus
traffic etc so when it breaks you also
have to know how to fix uh in the day to
operation
so when you mention this the interviewer
might ask is there any way to reduce
this pain
yeah couple of ways one is you can use
the eks blueprints that i showed which
kind of installs all the add-ons from
the day to operation side
you can mention you can use tools like
rancher rafae
which makes your day to operation a
little bit easier
next question what is a multi-stage
build
if you look into a docker file you can
see that each line is a command so when
these commands are executed it creates a
layer or intermediate images for example
when the from python colon 3.8 is run
it creates a layer for this command
similarly each commands keep on adding
more layers to the container image
and your final docker container image is
the collection of these layers
you want the size of your container
image as low as possible and to do that
you should reduce the number of layers
how do you reduce the number of layers
so if you think about it
at the end of the day all the docker
file is doing is
it is taking your code
installing the dependencies and
compiling it and then creating a
executable
and once you have this executable
it can run anywhere right because once
you have this exe file or a jar file
or the golang
final package file you do not need to
have the code and dependencies anymore
that final artifact is able to run by
itself
so your final docker container image can
just have this final executable artifact
and you should be fine
so multi-stage build achieves that so
with multi-stage build you can have
multiple stages in the same docker file
so let's say stage one you have the
large base image and then you install
the code and dependencies and then you
compile your code to an executable
artifact
and on the second stage
you take the small base image and just
copy the executable into that small base
image and you create the final docker
container for your application from this
next stage and all these multiple stages
can be done in the same docker file so
let's take a look at an example so if we
look at a multi-stage docker file
so on stage one it is grabbing the
golang version 1.7.3 and this as
builder is the name of the stage
so the name of the stage is builder and
the final line of this stage it is
compiling the code and creating the
final artifact now in the same docker
file you can see we are grabbing the
lightweight image and anytime there is a
from statement in the docker file that
means a new stage starts and in this
stage i am simply copying the compiled
code from builder stage you can see i am
referring the previous stage with dash
dash from equals to builder and the
docker container image will only be
built from the last stage so in this
case if you created your docker
container from just stage one the size
will be much larger but on the second
stage since we are using the lightweight
image and only copying the executable
artifact the size will be much less
last question now that docker desktop
charges money will that impact your
kubernetes workload
so the answer is no and the interviewer
might ask why
so basically all the container runtime
is built based on open container
initiative so this specifies
the image specification so once you have
a container image it should run on any
container runtime that is compliant to
oci
so think of this like a swagger file for
api
once you have a swagger file you can run
it in any api management platform good
thing is the docker is a container
runtime it is oci compliant
so is container d and crio so even if
you created your container image using
docker file that has nothing to do with
the container runtime so the container
image will become oci compliant so this
container image can run on any oci
compliant container runtime so amazon
eks uses container d as the container
runtime that's also ci compliant
so your workload should run fine in
kubernetes the only thing that's
impacted by the docker desktop license
is the
local machine features like you could
spin up a kubernetes cluster in a local
machine some of the security features
etc you can look up the alternatives
there are a bunch of alternatives on
docker desktop so you can google that or
i have a separate video on that you can
check that out as well
hopefully this video was helpful in your
interview preparation or in general
kubernetes studying
uh please click that subscribe button
only 15 of you are subscribed to my
channel i regularly create content like
this for your interview preparation
kubernetes deep dive demo serverless
devops etc
also if you are looking to learn
kubernetes system design serverless
infrastructure as code check out my best
selling and highest rated courses in
udemy
there is a special mother's day sale
going on i'll give the link down below
uh that helps this channel grow as well
as helps me
create more content for you all right
folks that's it for this one i'll see
you guys and girls in the next video bye